let me start with congratulations on
peacemaker i saw the first seven and i
was begging james to have him show me
episode eight and he's like no way
stephen it it is
i love episode eight in a way that i
cannot even describe hey and listen
you'll when you see you'll see why we
did not
reveal it uh earlier but you know it is
the culmination of all these incredibly
intricate threads that he has been
weaving through one and one through
seven they all come together beautifully
in one way and i i love it i mean i i
think that you know one of the great
things that james has been able to do is
to give true character development and
arcs to the entire ensemble not just
yeah he told me i was wondering if it
was a vfx reason but he's like no it's
just for spoilers he's like i don't want
them getting out there i'm like i don't
blame you you know i get it
you've produced a number of things but i
know there must be some stuff in your
back pocket that you're waiting to get
made so if you had the ability to get
the financing for any project tomorrow
what would be the thing that you make
and why
i think it has to be the
javelin weasel odd couple show they live
together in new york they're roommates
and it's just uh their life together in
new york city no i i i
you know listen
you know we have some other things in
development that are things that are
real priorities um you know some
spin-offs some originals um i i think dc
has such a deep well of characters and
ultimately what it comes down to is you
know finding the right filmmaker to pair
to pair those properties up with because
you need a james gunn to say you know
what would make the suicide squad work
let's do it as a 1970s war caper movie
you know
i don't even mean just dc i just mean in
general like is there a script that
you've had for like years you're like
this needs to get made
uh
okay yes then i'll tell you there there
is one
it's written by this brilliant it's
gonna sound weird this british historian
simon sebag montefiore it's called
winston and joe and it is about the
first meeting of winston churchill and
joseph stalin in 1942 in moscow when
churchill travels there to meet with him
and basically
keep him you know from capitulating uh
it is
it's like frost nixon but with those two
great characters that is one i would
like to make so stephen if you could if
you could provide the financing for that
i'm ready to go make that movie this
year
i you know something sometimes putting
it out into the ether like this you
never even know you know i think it's
the first time i've said it out loud so
this this could be my manifestation of
it thank you exactly so you've been
working with james i believe since 2007
2008 it's been a long time maybe even
earlier and i don't know um what do you
think would surprise people to learn
about james based on your long history
of working with him
you know i don't know that people be
surprised because james is very
he wears his heart on a sleeve you know
james is is pretty pretty much an open
book uh you know creatively the things
that he loves the things that he hates
you know he's never really hidden uh who
he is so i don't know that people would
necessarily be surprised by by anything
uh about him other than
you know
no i think people know people know who
he is if you've seen slither super
guardians of the galaxy
peacemaker and the suicide squad you
really know a lot about james because
he's been given incredible freedom uh
creatively to make these shows and and
to talk about the things that are
meaningful to him whether it's toxic
masculinity father-son relationships
mother-daughter relationships familial
relationships uh darkness depression
what it's like to be an underdog um uh
what it's like to be an outsider you
know i think he's pretty uh he's pretty
much an open book
so obviously like everyone uh i love
eagley and uh obviously eagley's gonna
be one of the favorites of the series
what was it like for you though because
you're making this obviously on a budget
what was it like when you read the
scripts and james is telling you um yeah
we're gonna have a bald eagle as a you
know as his pet and he's going to be a
really big part of the series
oh i i love that he always talked about
eagerly even before he wrote these
episodes i think he really talked about
the bald eagle that was his sidekick
slash best friend
i love how james anthro
for more fun
anthropomorphizes uh
animals and you know if he can make you
care about a talking tree or a raccoon
or what he did with sebastian or weasel
in the suicide squad
i couldn't wait to see what he was going
to do with eagley and i love the
character and i i love
and you know you've seen it just you
know there's kind of a nurturing side to
him he really wants to protect and look
after his best friend peacemaker i i
love what he did with it so no we we
embraced the idea of eagley as did hbo
max instantaneously
yeah uh
yeah i also the thing about james is he
makes all of his
animal characters feel flesh and blood
you know what i mean like you really
care about these characters very very
much so very very much so i mean listen
even from that first episode where you
know eagley puts his wings around
uh about around peacemaker and then the
kind of callback to that later on you
know it brings a tear to your eye it's
beautiful you can't believe that you are
emotionally engaged
in a bald eagle hug hugging a
reprehensible human being like
christopher smith
no i i'm a hundred percent agree with
you um uh obviously so i spoke i'm gonna
bring up something else i spoke to zach
listen you know i love shazam and i was
fortunate enough to be on set and i
spoke to zack recently and he thinks
that the sequel is even better than the
first
and i'm just and i'm just curious do you
agree with that obviously i'm sure you
agree but what what can you say about it
well you know even though this is a
peacemaker conversation but
i loved the first shazam movie i thought
it was i thought it was beautifully done
i thought that that david sandberg
nailed that tone so incredibly well the
eye of the needle was so small to get it
right but he really did nail it
i feel like this second one has
more emotion
more humor but it also has bigger action
bigger set pieces some great villains i
just feel like it's everything that we
loved in the first movie but really
turned up to 11. so i i i love it i
think the addition of some of these new
characters with uh you know rachel
ziegler and helen maron and lucy liu are
fantastic additions um i love that you
know the kids are all a little bit older
now so we get to have a little bit more
fun in kind of an edgier fashion with
them um but yeah and and you know zach
inhabits that character in such a
beautiful fashion so uh you know to have
been able to make a second one of those
it's a thrill
well also the other thing is when you're
making the first movie of anything
you're figuring out what's going to work
and what resonates with the fans and
it's like you know the first film is so
good and people love it i'm sure that
gave you more freedom on set to further
push what you wanted to do yeah i think
it did i mean you know listen the glory
of having the same filmmaker david
sandberg who you know had lived through
the first one and then really knew what
he wanted for the second one to to amp
it up um you know
made it it was it was actually an
incredibly
uh
it was a great shoot it was very very
smooth we had an incredible script from
uh uh henry gayden and uh and and chris
morgan um
so it was a really smooth shoot and and
i think you know now obviously having
seen you know cuts of the movie you know
it's really reflected in uh in that
final product
yeah i'm already given the wrap-up
signal i will just say that um i just
have to tell you that the opening
credits on peacemaker are a plus
i love them so much that i could i could
keep screaming about how you want to
taste it that's all i got do you want to
taste it no i mean listen james wrote
that choreography into the very first
draft that i ever read of episode one he
was like you know here's the intro
here's the dance number here's the fully
choreographed dance number that they
take really seriously that they are just
taking it really soon and that was it he
always knew what he knew what he wanted
but i love it and i hope we've created
something that's unskippable i hope
people will watch it each time oh i
watched all seven episodes and in every
single time it brought a smile to my
face
that's great that's great well we're
bringing back hair metal
i love it um hey listen man i wish you
nothing but the best yeah we'll chat
soon yeah and
obviously there's a lot more to talk
about uh soon yeah yeah absolutely i
look forward to it
you